[MUSIC PLAYING]
- Good afternoon, everyone.
I'm delighted to see you.
I'm Liz Cohen.
I'm Dean of the
Radcliffe Institute.
We have a very full
house here today.
Thank you all for joining us.
I'm very much looking forward
to our discussion, "The Museum,
the City, and the University."
Our program today reflects
Radcliffe's dual mission
to support scholars, scientists,
and artists as they pursue
innovative research
and creative work,
and to share the fruits of those
endeavors with the wide public
through lectures,
conferences, exhibitions.
And discussions like
today's I am excited to dive
into what I know will be
a fascinating discussion
about the present and future of
three institutions that matter
a great deal to me, and I
would guess to many of you
in this room--
the art museum, the
university, and the city.
To guide us, we are
fortunate to have
five leaders of Boston's
major art museums,
as well as our distinguished
moderator, Harvard
and Radcliffe's own
professor Yukio Lippit.
Museums and universities have
distinctive but overlapping
missions in today's society.
Both are committed to
preserving cultural knowledge
in abstract and material form.
Both are dedicated to advancing
new knowledge, new research.
And they share a common
mission to communicate
ideas and aesthetic appreciation
in a variety of ways
to broad constituencies.
These links between museums
and universities are not new.
They have a long history.
When Western European
nations were first forming
and monarchs were
consolidating their power,
universities and
lavish collections
of art and antiquities played
important and complementary
roles in their societies.
Teaching and
research universities
helped solidify
national identities,
and royal collections
glorified the crown
and conferred legitimacy.
Both also preserved the
ideological and material
culture of their
patrons for the future.
In the 18th and 19th centuries,
when many of the major museums
we know today emerged as
important cultural institutions
in cities around
the world, they took
on important societal objectives
and engaged a much broader
public.
Not only did their
collecting and research
commitments expand, but as
democratic government took hold
in the Western world,
museums aspired
to use their cultural
treasures to cultivate
enlightened citizens.
Here in the United States, the
19th and early 20th centuries
also saw massive immigration
to Boston, New York,
and other major cities.
The Boston Museum of Fine Arts
and the Metropolitan Museum
of Art in New York,
both founded in 1870,
aimed to serve as
Americanizing institutions
in urban centers
that were exploding
in size and population.
Much has changed, of course,
between the 1870s and today.
But deep connections live
on between national identity
and collections of
visual material culture,
between museums and universities
as preservers and promoters
of new knowledge, and between
museums and their publics.
To highlight one
very recent example,
earlier this year, our five
panelists wrote an open letter
eloquently defending the
National Arts and Humanities
endowments and articulating
their shared belief,
and I quote, that
"access to the arts
is at the core of a democratic
and equitable society."
End quote.
These issues have taken on
greater urgency and importance
in recent years and even months.
We are watching as public
support for the arts
and humanities is
increasingly contested.
We are experiencing a new
wave of nativism and pressures
for Americanization
that surely have
implications for the missions of
universities and museums alike.
And as American cities
struggle for economic survival,
their museums face
pressures to be
engines of growth
and development,
in addition to their
traditional roles in education
and research, potentially
leading to conflicting agendas.
Finally, current
political realities
make museums' efforts to
engage the public in the arts
and humanities both more
important and potentially more
difficult than ever before.
I am grateful that we have
with us this afternoon
such a distinguished panel
to help us explore and better
understand some of these issues,
and surely others as well.
Before I hand things
over to Yukio Lippit,
let me invite you all to
continue the conversation
with our panelists and with
each other at a reception
immediately following this
program right next door at Fay
House.
Now, to get our
program started, please
join me in welcoming Yukio
Lippit to the podium.
Yukio is a professor
of art and architecture
at Harvard, an expert
in Japanese art
with extensive
experience creating
museum exhibitions, and the
Johnson-Kulukundis Family
Faculty Director
of the arts here
at the Radcliffe Institute.
Yukio?
[APPLAUSE]
Hello, everyone, and
let me join Dean Cohen
and welcome you to what
promises to be a special event.
In the greater
Boston area, we're
fortunate enough to have art
museums of the highest caliber.
The Museum of Fine Arts is
one of the great encyclopedic
museums anywhere in the
world, with collections second
to none.
The Isabella Stewart
Gardner Museum close by
is a real cultural treasure
of the city of Boston,
one of the remarkable
museums that emerged out
of the Gilded Age, and
its collections housed
in an unforgettable setting.
Through dynamic programming
and landmark exhibitions,
the Institute of
Contemporary Ar in Boston
has been a leader
in the art world
since its opening in the 1930s.
Similarly, the List Center
for the Visual Arts at MIT
has been a true center for
innovation and experimentation
in the arts since its founding
as the Heaton Gallery in 1950.
And the Harvard Art
Museums together
constitute one of the
leading research museums
worldwide These museums
represent very different kinds
of institutions, but
each in their own way
constitutes an important
part of the region's history
and contributes vitally to
its character in the present.
This evening, we're
fortunate enough
to be able to engage
in conversation
with their respective directors.
They come from
different backgrounds,
but all share a broad
set of experiences
touching upon many different
aspects of the art world.
They have curated exhibitions,
authored scholarly articles,
purchased art,
hired museum staff,
discovered new works,
written opinion pieces,
founded NPOs, conceived
of innovative programs,
crafted partnerships
and strategic plans
in overseeing complex
building projects.
They have also been
known to raise money.
They are art lovers first
and foremost, but also
scholars, historians, curators,
planners, educators, designers,
and leaders of the
community, as witnessed
among other things in
the powerful letter
cited by Dean Cohen that
they coauthored in February
of this year to protest proposed
cuts to the National Endowment
of the Arts and Humanities.
In the summer of
2015, we were faced
with an unusual circumstance
here in the Boston area.
Three of the region's
museums, the Gardner, the MFA,
and the Harvard Art
Museum, had vacancies
in the director's position.
There was a feeling that
once these seats were filled,
there would
inevitably be a shift
in the cultural landscape.
We hoped to invite whoever
assumed these directorships
to the Radcliffe Institute
in to participate
in an event such as this one.
However, time has a way of
passing, and at this point,
they already seem like veterans
of our local art world.
So we decided to
shoot for the moon
and not only invite our new
directors, Peggy Fogelman,
Matthew Teitelbaum,
and Martha Tedeschi,
but also ask them to be
joined by our longer-serving
directors, Jill
Medvedow and Paul Ha,
in a wide-ranging discussion
here at the Radcliffe Institute
for our Harvard
Radcliffe community,
about the museum, the
city, and the university.
And somehow, we succeeded.
It goes without
saying that they're
extraordinarily busy
people, and we're
extremely grateful for
their time and enthusiasm
in joining us today.
And before introducing
our participants
and inviting them
to the stage, let
me just say a few words about
how this evening will proceed.
After our roughly
hour-long discussion,
there'll be time for a
question and answer period.
And microphones will be placed
in the center of the aisle
here, and if you
have a question,
we ask that you
come to the aisle
and state your name
and any affiliation
before posing your question.
Then afterwards,
as Dean Cohen said,
we invite you to join us
for a reception in Fay House
next door.
Now, let me introduce
our participants.
Peggy Fogelman began her career
as a curator of sculpture
at the J. Paul Getty Museum and
has had a distinguished career
as a curator, educator,
and in senior management,
not just at the Getty
but at the Peabody Essex
museum in Salem, and
serving from 2009
as the chairman of education at
the Metropolitan Museum of Art.
Subsequently, she served
as director of collections
at the Morgan Library and Museum
before moving here in 2016
to become the Norma
Jean Calderwood
Director of the Gardner Museum.
Paul Ha was formerly the
director of White Columns Art
Gallery in New York
before becoming
deputy director of programs
at the Yale University Art
Gallery.
In 2002, he moved to the
Contemporary Art Museum
in St. Louis, where
he served as director
and oversaw the
construction and opening
of its newly expanded facility.
There, he created the
first major museum exhibit
for a wide range of now
internationally recognized
artists, and he has
served as director
of the List since 2011.
Jill Medvedow served
as the first curator
for contemporary art
at the Gardner Museum,
as well as the deputy
director of programs
before assuming the
directorship of the ICA in 1998,
where she now serves as the
Ellen Matilda Poss Director.
She was the founder of 911
Contemporary Arts in Seattle
and has served as deputy
director of the New England
Foundation for the Arts.
And as many of us
know here, she oversaw
the building and opening in
2006 of the current ICA building
in the Seaport District
in South Boston,
which has become a true
cultural landmark of the city.
Martha Tedeschi began her
career in the Department
of Prints and Drawings at
the Chicago Art Institute,
specializing in British
and American art.
After a distinguished
and award winning career
as a curator and author,
she became deputy director
of art research
in Chicago, where
she developed innovative
curatorial programming
in partnerships with
local universities
before coming to Harvard in 2016
as the Elizabeth ad John Moors
Cabot Director of the
Harvard Art Museums.
Matthew Teitelbaum
was previously
a curator at the ICA Boston and
Mendel Art Gallery in Saskatoon
before joining the
Art Gallery of Ontario
in 1993 as chief curator.
He was then appointed director
and CEO of the art gallery
in 1998 and oversaw a wide range
of exhibitions and programming
as well as the renovation
of its Bozar Building
by Frank Gehry,
completed in 2008.
He was awarded,
among other prizes,
the Chevalier dans l'Ordre des
Arts et des Lettres in 2006,
and in 2015, he joined the
MFA as the Ann and Graham Gund
Director.
Please join me in welcoming
our directors to the stage.
[APPLAUSE]
- Oh, sorry.
- There's a chair.
- Well, we can read.
- So we'd like to start off
this conversation by giving you
an opportunity to
speak in a more
personal vein about your
relationship to museums.
Was there a formative
museum experience
at some point in your lives,
in your childhood, perhaps,
that led you down this path?
Martha, maybe we
can begin with you,
as something of a co-host
of this conversation.
- Yes, there definitely for
me was a cataclysmic moment.
And it was when I
was eight years old,
and my family had just
moved to Florence, Italy,
about six months after
the devastating flooding
of the Arno River, which
destroyed works of art,
flooded the basement of the
Biblioteca Nazionale archives,
where books were destroyed.
Palazzi with beautiful frescoed
walls were critically damaged.
And although I
was a little girl,
I was very aware of what was
happening, because there was
scaffolding all over Florence.
There still is, sort of.
But scaffolding everywhere,
mud lines on all the buildings.
And what was really
remarkable is
that there was an outpouring
of help from all over Europe,
and conservators and especially
university students were
everywhere in Florence, trying
to help with documentation,
preservation, just,
really, triage.
And so it was a tragic but
also heroic environment,
and it was that
year that I began
to understand the precariousness
and the preciousness
of our cultural heritage.
And I think ever
since then, I felt
protective of museum collections
from that experience.
- That's wonderful.
Jill?
- I would say my formative
childhood experience was
at the Yale
University Art Gallery
in New Haven, Connecticut,
where I grew up.
And it was a place I
could take the bus too,
because I lived
right in the city.
And as a young person,
I was completely
taken by the great Duchamp Tu
m' that hangs at the museum.
You know it well.
And I think that--
I don't know how as a young
person I thought I got it,
but for some reason
I thought I did,
and that made me very excited.
And I think ever since
then, that combination
of verbal and visual thinking
and punning and ideas--
it caught me then, and that
was a perfect museum for me.
New Haven's a small
city that I love dearly,
but it took my pretty
insular world, of growing up
Jewish in a Jewish community in
a small city where my dad was
a politician, and it was the
one place where the world just
exploded for me,
and it was mine.
And that changed me forever.
- Well, as painful
it is to admit,
the Yale University
Art Gallery is really
one of the gold standards
of university museums.
- I ought to be an ad
for them all the time.
- Well, this leads to
a question that we also
wanted to start off
the evening with,
which has to do with
the city of Boston
and how the city of Boston
looks through the prism
of your museums.
You have all directed museums
in other major North American
cities--
Toronto, St. Louis, Los
Angeles, Chicago, New York.
How does Boston appear to you?
And maybe that's
a question we can
direct to our two more
recently appointed directors,
Peggy and Matthew.
- If I can jump in.
So one of the things that
Dean Cohen said that really
resonated with me--
you were talking about
that Boston was
very different when
our museums were established,
but not so different.
And in fact, that's true.
And the situation in Boston
compared to the situation now--
at the turn of the century,
Boston was 35% foreign-born.
Now, it's 25% foreign-born.
And so in looking at the
city through the prism
of the Gardner, the Gardner
has very progressive roots
that one might not suspect when
you think of an unconventional
woman in the Gilded
Age, who, granted,
was quite wealthy and quite
privileged-- nonetheless she
specifically established
a museum for the public.
Unlike other Gilded
Age museums, it
was not a private collection
that became public after death.
It was amassed and
intended for the public.
And she herself had very
progressive political leanings,
and so I think that
that's embedded
in the DNA of the institution.
And that's our imperative.
I think that's an imperative for
all of us in our institutions,
to reflect the city
and our audiences.
However, in
considering the city,
I think we have a
lot of challenges.
And we certainly are
not, in this room,
or in many of the things we
do, reflective of the city
in which we live.
And I think that
is something that
remains a challenge in Boston.
Perhaps more so than
in some other places,
although I think
overall, it's a challenge
for our cultural institutions
in terms of that imperative
to really engage broadly
and to be truly welcoming.
- So let me just
start by saying--
answering your first
question, which
maybe has something to do with
the second question, which
is when I was about 10,
I went to an exhibition
with my father,
who was an artist.
And his favorite artist in
the world was Rembrandt,
and it was a Rembrandt show.
And I remember at the
end of the exhibition,
he said that I have to
go home and have a nap.
And I looked at him and I said,
but we just looked at art.
He said, well, looking
at art is work, right?
And I clearly never
forgot that, that notion
that the experience of
looking at a work of art
is commensurate with
what you put into it
and what you get back, and
that it is actually a project.
It is a commitment.
And I think about that
in relation to the MFA.
So I am the only
person on the stage
who not only has
come to a new city
but has come to a new country.
And I suppose what I would
say is, in Toronto, I
thought a lot about how
the museum that I led
was helping create the city.
I'm not saying that
we didn't reflect it.
I didn't say that we
didn't reach out and pull
in that energy.
But I was also very conscious
of how a museum can create
a dialogue within a city.
And if I were thinking
about the role
that I think the MFA
and all of us can play,
it's how we do create
the citizen in our midst.
And I think we have an
obligation to do that.
And I think that Boston is more
diverse than it first seems,
but I have to say, as a
Canadian, a Torontonian,
it doesn't seem that diverse.
And I think that
one of my challenges
is to figure out how to tap into
the diversity that does exist
here and how to give back
a sense of citizenship
and community, which I
think museums must do.
- Paul?
- What I'm observing
is that there
is an incredible moment of
growth in the visual arts
here in Boston.
I think Boston is facing sort
of a renaissance in the arts,
especially in the visual arts.
And when you think about
what institution has grown,
you look at Gardner, you look
at MFA, you look at Harvard.
They've all done
incredible capital projects
and have made new
beginnings for themselves
and inserted themselves
into our culture.
And art does create economies.
So when you think about all
the money that's been put in,
all the jobs, that's been given
to create these institutions.
And this is the moment where
when I make Jill embarrassed,
and I always say this.
I really feel that
we're in this position
now because 11 years
ago, the ICA was created.
And this city hasn't created
a new museum in 100 years,
and Jill went ahead
and put that museum
on the beautiful waterfront.
And I think that
got people thinking
that the city can change.
We've been the same
for a long time.
It's been fantastic.
But maybe there's growth.
Maybe there's other
ways to do it.
And I do think there's
incredible organizations
all throughout Boston.
But I think especially
in the visual arts,
there's an enormous growth.
- Well, thank you.
This really mean segues into
a question about architecture.
And all of you are a part of--
you lead museums that are
housed in very different kinds
of buildings.
This is immediately, of course,
apparent to a first-time museum
visitor, and the
experience of the museum
is one and the same as the
experience of the architecture
and the space.
And now is a really
wonderful opportunity,
while we have you here on
stage, to ask you to give us
a sense, an insider's
sense of your buildings,
of your architecture,
as directors.
Are there any ways in which
the buildings surprise you?
- That's very funny.
[LAUGHTER]
I wasn't exactly
intending it to be funny,
but please go with that.
- I was just going
to say, absolutely.
Yes, what I've found getting
to know the relatively new
building of the Harvard
Art Museums-- which,
for those of you who don't know,
opened in November of 2014,
so we're getting close
to celebrating our third
anniversary in the building--
I think a huge
amount of work was
done to try to have the
mission of the museum
inform the building.
What's interesting now that
it's open is the spaces.
And we created a lot of
differentiated spaces
for different kinds of learning.
The spaces are actually, in
some cases, driving the program
and actually giving
people more of an appetite
than we thought for access
to original works of art.
So the suite of study centers on
the fourth floor, for example.
That was a lot of
real estate to give up
in a museum building project.
But because we have
that there, and we
are making it
staffed all the time,
last year, 41,000 objects came
through those study centers.
That is an appetite
I don't think
anybody could have predicted.
And similarly, we have
an experimental space
called the Lightbox
space that has
started to be a
site for research
with collaborators
across Harvard.
We didn't really know whether it
would be a place to show film,
or whether we would
commission artists
working in digital media.
But this space itself is
suggesting possibilities
to our collaborators.
So I could give many
more examples of that.
But I think what
we're finding is
that very differentiated spaces
in a new architectural building
sometimes have surprises.
- So your recommendation
is to build a building
and do the programming later?
[LAUGHTER]
- Well, I guess my
recommendation would
be, listen to the
building, and push it
to see what it can do for you.
And I think what it's doing for
us is growing organically now.
- Thank you.
- Jill?
- I must say, I'm
more interested
in the buildings around us than
in our individual buildings,
all of which do very
different things.
But I think that in
thinking about the city,
part of what the questions that
at least I'm grappling with
are-- it's fantastic
to be the first new art
museum in a century.
Nothing for a city
to be proud of,
so to go to your first question
about what's happening here
in Boston, I think we're still
kind of trying to catch up,
in many ways, from a fairly
conservative attitude
towards architecture, towards
building, towards museums,
certainly towards
contemporary art.
And we've seen an accelerated
pace in the last decade.
But I think that it's important
to look at the issues of zoning
and planning, of the relative
power and roles of developers
versus civic institutions
in actually shaping
the face of the city, of
where power gets centered.
And in many ways, my
beautiful beloved ICA,
which works incredibly well
when you get in the door
and is making many, many, many
people happy all the time--
but it is completely consumed
by privatized large buildings.
And so as a city, I think
it's necessary to take
a look at what we value.
Many other cities have
made different choices
in terms of their
waterfront, and might
have left some space open around
their iconic architecture.
Our city did not
choose to do that.
We can handle that.
We never thought
we would be alone.
And just as I'm happy to
have all my colleagues,
I am actually happy to
have people in buildings
than on the waterfront.
But I think that it's
a much bigger question
than our architecture.
We are punctuation marks in a
city that is, in its center,
exploding.
But it's a city
that extends well
beyond the Fenway, Harvard
Square, and the seaport
in Kendall Square.
And so I think we have some
really difficult questions
to grapple with,
architecturally.
- In that context,
one of the qualities
of the architecture
that expresses itself
in different ways in
our different spaces,
because each is unique,
is this idea of sanctuary,
of putting yourself in a
different kind of space,
a different kind
of mental space,
of physical space.
And I think that in some ways,
the growth of Boston and that
the pace of development
and the pace of work
and the pace of life in Boston,
which is ever-increasing,
in fact creates both a
hunger and an opportunity
for our cultural organizations,
our cultural spaces,
our performative spaces,
to serve a role in terms
of civic life and in
terms of all of life
that perhaps they
didn't so much before,
when things weren't necessarily
booming in every corner
all around us.
So that's physically
manifested around the ICA,
but I think it's emotionally
and psychologically manifested
throughout the
city, even when it's
not actually right next door.
- So I might say that I'm
not particularly interested
in the idea of sanctuary.
I'm not sure whether
you said you were.
But the challenge with
the MFA is, in fact,
to move away from that.
And if the future of the
museum, which I believe it is,
is about invitation,
welcome engagement,
how do you invite people
into your institution
and say we want you here, how
do you welcome them and say you
belong here, and how
do you engage them
and say you can learn here
and share experiences here--
then when I think of the MFA,
and you asked about surprises,
I am constantly
surprised-- and maybe I
shouldn't be-- at how forbidding
the exterior of the building,
is how uninviting it is.
I do have folks around the
MFA who don't understand me
when I say that and say,
but I feel comfortable here.
And I think that's my point.
My response is,
if you like going
to the Supreme Court or the
central bank, then you're good.
So what do you do with the
outside of the building?
And I had a great privilege.
In fact, one of the great
privileges of my life
was to work with Frank Gehry
on the Toronto building.
And he taught me a lot
about architecture.
In fact, I had a rule that
whenever he said something
that I didn't agree with
or didn't understand,
I'd ask him to say
why because I thought,
when am I going to have an
experience like this again?
And it was really
life-affirming.
But one of the things I realized
was that a building is not
a building.
I never actually
said that to him,
but a building isn't a building.
We weren't building a building.
We were building an experience.
And if you think about a
building as an experience,
then you end up thinking
about it as a journey.
And one of the big surprises for
me about the MFA as a building
is how unrewarding
it is as a journey.
I'm not saying you
don't have great things.
I'm not saying that we
don't have great moments.
Of course we do.
But the notion of
how you feel when you
move through that building--
not so rewarding, not so
exciting, not so affirming.
The art is, the building
needs greater coherence.
- Thank you.
- That's the beginning
of a capital campaign.
[LAUGHTER]
- Thank you.
Would you like to
follow up a little bit?
- I just want to address
the concept of sanctuary.
And I think this also
goes to the issue
of welcoming audiences.
I think we have to become, as
organizations, as institutions,
much less judgmental about
what is a valid experience
in our spaces.
And we know from a lot
of evaluation and visit
or research that people,
particularly millennials who
seem to be leading very
overstressed lives,
actually come to museums
seeking a sort of sanctuary,
a sort of ability to
take themselves out
of their everyday heads and
inhabit a different kind
of mental space.
And of course, the
Gardner broadcasts an idea
of reflection and sanctuary in
terms of its courtyard, which
is the heart of the place.
Which does not mean
that we're not also
engaging people very
actively in terms
of participatory experiences
and performative experience.
But I do think if we talk
about being truly welcoming
and wanting very broad,
diverse audiences
to find meaning in
our institutions, that
means every mode
of engagement that
doesn't endanger the collection
needs to be validated.
Because for so long--
for centuries, in fact--
we have conditioned
our audiences
to conduct themselves certain
ways in relation to art.
And much of that has been
very intellectually driven
by a certain kind of pedagogy.
And I think to be truly
meaningful, we have to let go.
- I know that our architects,
Diller Scofidio and Renfro,
were fond of saying
that the ICA was built
to be civic from the
ground up and contemplative
from the sky down.
And I think it's worked in
many ways, in that sense.
But of course, the
word "sanctuary" today
has such a particular meaning.
And so I think that
we are so many things.
I mean, museums-- and we're
among the smaller ones,
relative certainly to the MFA--
but we're complex institutions.
Museums are complex
institutions and beings,
and they have all
these different ways,
all these different centers
of business and operation
and different collections,
different approaches
to collections, diverse
constituencies, donors,
that I do think we
are used to being
many things for many people.
And regardless of how we say it,
we are all trying to, I think
be, as open and
inviting as we can,
to offer this wealth of
learning, teaching, reflection,
engagement.
Some of it's individual
and private, and some of it
is in fantastic groups of young
kids, teenagers, millennials,
and seniors.
It's like the gamut.
It's our great
strength, I think.
- I think for museums, it's not
really about the architecture.
And having overseen
three capital projects,
working with a young Stan Allen
and overseeing the Louis Kahn
building--
what I know is, just
like your houses,
all the museums will
leak one of these days.
And that's what we live with.
But I think once the
building gets built,
we don't really think
about the structure,
but what we think
about is the program.
And ultimately, I think
my job is to put someone
in front of an object.
And it's about, how do
we get someone in here?
And it's great to have an iconic
building that the mayor can
show off and tell, as they say,
what progress we're making.
But in the end, it's about
creating programs and ideas
and getting people in so they
feel invited and welcomed,
and it becomes their space.
- We're starting a new
building program which I think
we'll learn quite a bit from.
But we're taking a
condemned building--
so in a neighborhood in East
Boston, in the East Boston
shipyard and marina, and taking
it out of total disrepair
to be a free, open, free all
the time, open seasonally space,
and trying to keep it
as raw and industrial
and pointing to its history
as possible, which is actually
a very difficult thing to do.
Simple seems to be both more
expensive and more complex
than one might think.
- It's very expensive
to look cheap.
I know.
Getting good at that.
But it will be, I think,
really interesting to see how
these two spaces that
bookend the harbor--
and where when we first
opened on Fan Pier,
we thought one of our
great civic initiatives
was access to the harbor.
And now we see that
part of how we address
the civic role of the
museum and the city
is actually thinking about
public transportation
across the harbor.
So I think a lot,
over the past decade,
it's a different shift of our
relationship to architecture
and the city.
- Well, thank you.
And I'd like to get back
to that point in a moment,
but one of the
interesting things that
has emerged from what I'm
hearing of this conversation
is that there isn't
necessarily a tension
between this immersive, tranquil
encounter with the object
that, Jill, you
beautifully described
from your experiences at the
Yale University Art Gallery,
and the more bustling zeitgeist
blockbuster exhibition,
where there is more of
a density of visitors.
But let me rephrase the
question a little bit
in terms of modes of attention.
This is something
that we struggle
with a lot at the university--
how to capture student attention
at its most basic level,
but also how to understand
the way attention is changing,
and to not try to
reverse trends,
but to try to understand
and accommodate
and take advantage of
the state of things.
And we're doing it.
Yes, we are banning laptops
and wireless devices
from classrooms on occasion, but
we're also flipping classrooms
and trying to get students
to talk to each other
more and take a more
participatory role, of course,
in class.
And how does this question get
addressed today at the museum?
The question about attention.
- I'm happy to jump in
there, specifically thinking
about engaging
students, which is
such a big part of our mission.
And we really find that
the students want to use us
in many different ways.
And one of the things we have
to keep reiterating to them
is that there's no
right way or wrong way
to use the museum
and its collections.
And we tried to make sure,
when we had our kickoff student
late night, we thought
about the modes of attention
very clearly, and we created all
different levels of intimacy,
all the way over to a public
meeting with a big sound DJ who
was filling the building.
So that was the courtyard.
But then, as students moved
throughout the building,
we were able to get
more and more intimate,
so that they could have
one-on-one experiences
with an object, they could
follow a small guided tour
by a peer.
But the idea of
differentiating, so
that you reach people at
their level of attention
on that particular day.
Because I think
modes of attention
also reflect the reason
you came to the museum
in the first place.
Museum research often
shows that visitors
will have a good or bad
experience in the museum based
on what they wanted the
outcome of their visit to be.
So if you're coming
with a social purpose--
let's say you have
friends from out of town--
you're going to want
to make that experience
work for your friends.
You want to feel
empowered to show them
around without getting lost.
There are certain
things you need.
On the other hand,
we hear from students
all the time that we're their
favorite place to go to be sad.
Which sounds like not
a compliment, maybe,
but think about it.
For students who are
sharing dorm rooms,
don't have much
privacy, may never
feel comfortable
going to church,
but need something along those
lines to help them calm down,
slow down, think, feel, get in
touch with their own feelings,
have some privacy--
we also hear that
students want that.
And then we also heard
that behind our building
was the best place at
Harvard to smoke pot.
[LAUGHTER]
- This is getting
very interesting.
- Well, let me just say, if
you could tell your students
that we have 11 Mark
Rothko paintings,
they could come and be sad for
the next 11 months at the MFA.
But, you know, it's interesting.
Everybody has their own way of
understanding their audience.
In studies that
we've done, we found
the two reasons why people
want to come to a museum
are number one, to
be with other people,
and secondly, to
confront a point of view.
To confront a point of view.
So when I think about
that, where I go is--
and how does their
understanding get expressed?
So I'm certainly
interested in our position
and what we say, but I think
that public institutions
like the MFA--
and I run into trouble when I
say it's a public institution,
and what I mean is,
we serve the public--
have a responsibility in this
moment to think about voice.
How do we create voice
for our audience?
How do we create voice for our
community, within our walls?
And that's maybe why--
sorry to come back to it--
I have trouble with this
relatively passive notion
of sanctuary, reflection.
Because I think museums, more
urgently than in my experience,
need now to create the
enlightened citizen
and create activity and
action in our communities.
I don't think we
need to be polemical,
but I need to think we
have to create action.
And the way I think
we have to do it,
and the way that I want
the MFA to be judged,
is through the
eyes of the artist.
I think that if we
can create the MFA
as a platform for the
artistic sensibility,
to artistic thinking, the
sense of new possibility,
of putting things
together in new ways,
we will both be doing the
right thing generally, and more
specifically, giving the voice
to our audience, because they
will find a way to be with each
other, to learn something new,
to confront a point of view
that will make them more engaged
citizens.
And I believe that.
How we do that is the constant
conversation that we're having.
But I think we need,
at the MFA, to do
that more than we've done.
- I've grown up doing both
political organizing and art
and art history.
So I toggle quite a bit.
But when I hear
your question, I'm
going someplace a little
bit different, which
is the need to ensure that we--
part of being
somebody growing up,
and then an adult
and participant,
does require the
ability to read closely,
whether it's, as you said,
being able to give something
to a work of art so that
you can take something back,
or I think about language and
written language or literature
and poetry.
And I was reading something over
the weekend that made reference
to a really prescient
article by George Orwell
that he wrote right after World
War ii ended, I think in 1946,
talking about how
sloppy language is
so complicit in sloppy thinking
and in political danger.
So Hannah Arendt does the
same kind of connection.
And I think that we
also have an obligation
and an incredible opportunity
with our collections
and with the art we present
on stage or on our walls
to try to--
also, at the same time as we
get people to speak out and feel
engaged, active
citizens who vote--
that part of what we want
them to do when they vote
is to have thought
critically and deeply
and paid attention to the
words and the language.
And that does require attention.
And so I don't know if that's
what you're getting at,
but that's what it
made me think about.
- Yes, thank you.
Well, I wanted to follow
up on this a little bit.
Citizenship happens to be the
research theme of the Radcliffe
Institute this year and next.
It is, in part, a lead-up
to the celebration
of the centennial
of women's suffrage
and the ratification of the
19th Amendment of the US
Constitution.
And we're living in a
time where it's never
felt more pressing to
raise questions about what
it means to be a citizen.
It's never felt
more urgent to get
involved in civic engagement.
So could we elaborate
a little bit on this,
about where museums play a
role in the present discourse
on civic engagement?
- May I ask a question in
reference to your question?
And that is, why
do we, or do we,
make a distinction
between civic engagement
and cultural engagement?
Can one ask the question, is
cultural engagement actually
civic engagement, if we
believe in the power of art
to give voice to
ideas, to politics,
to the human condition, to this.
And I guess I would wonder
what my colleagues might
think of that particular
spin on the question.
- Thank you.
As museums, I feel like
our duty is to present.
We present things.
And so when things occur,
moments happen, and then
the staff has a meeting
To say, how do we react to
this, or not to react to it?
What can we do?
Should we do something?
Many questions.
The exhibition we have up now
is called Civil Disobedience,
and it's a survey of how people
have protested from the 1920s
onto currently.
And we're showing all sides
of political statements
and their dedication, their
belief, why they're doing this,
and also presenting
how they went
about giving their voice to the
cause, giving their concerns,
raising their voice.
And so for us to be political?
Perhaps not.
But to present, to reflect the
current, what's happening now,
I think you have to be reactive
to what's happening now.
- I would also add that I
think you have to be reactive,
but you can be specific
and maybe have more impact.
So thinking in terms of
civic engagement and museums
and how they might
foster that, I
think they're really looking
at your proximate communities
and looking at their
needs and figuring out
whether the museum is
actually a good partner
to help solve a problem.
A very small example from
the work that the Harvard Art
Museums is doing with
Cambridge French and Latin,
a high school in
Cambridge, which
is an incredibly
diverse high school.
We were contacted
by teachers there
to let us know that their AP
World History students had
identified a real gap
in their textbook, which
was there was very little
discussion of Islamic lands
or culture.
And the students
were asking for this.
It's a very diverse school and
includes many Muslim students.
And so we have actually of done
an intervention in this world
AP class, and we're addressing
that lack in the textbook
through the collections
in the museums.
So I think sometimes those very
specific projects are really
a great way to begin to foster
civic engagement in a very
doable way that impacts
your immediate community.
- I don't know if I can
respond to Peggy or not,
but let me talk about my doubt.
My doubt is around
the question of,
what is the right action
for a public institution
at this moment in our history?
What is the right
position to take?
And what is the
personal point of view,
what is the institutional
point of view, and what gets
activated by taking a position?
Which maybe goes to the notion
of being civically engaged.
So I think that my
role as a leader
is to help the
people with whom I
work to stay in the question
of why, rather than what.
And the what follows,
but the real question
is, why should we do something?
So I'll share a
hot-off-the-press example,
which I was sharing in
the green room before me.
We were actually talking about
personal things and relatives
and kids that were
misbehaving, but we actually
talked a little bit about
art when we were waiting.
And I was sharing
that a curator--
I don't know which one
it was at the MFA--
suggested that we put
together fairly quickly--
my kind of word--
a small exhibit of
figures that are kneeling.
And my first thought was,
if the curator at the MFA
wants to do something like
that, I'm going to say yes.
And then I said,
I didn't think so.
Because I think that's a
what question rather than
a why question.
And I think we would
have really blurred
the notion of the
artist's intention.
We would have blurred
the notion of what
we are saying as an
institution around what issue.
But I loved the fact that
there was a curator--
again, I don't know
who it is-- who
wanted to find a
way to say something
that they were feeling about.
But my doubt is
that the answers are
going to be easy to come to.
My doubt is that there's
an obvious right or wrong.
My doubt is that I'm
going to get it right,
because I've never worked--
I should say this--
with a staff that I
feel is more anxious
and concerned
about the times
in which they live
and the way in which they
have agency to do things.
And I'm trying constantly to
balance that urgency, which
I am completely sympathetic
to in any situation,
with the right role
of the institution.
And that's my doubt and
it's not a bad place to be.
It actually takes me
straight into the--
why did museums do what they do?
But I'm in that all the
time, more than I expected.
- Thank you.
- I'm kind of on the
proactive end of the spectrum,
I would say.
Because I think that one of
the great ways a museum gets
to demonstrate its civicness
isn't so much public,
because it actually shows
up in one's budget, which
is-- where do we
spend our money,
and what priorities does
that actually demonstrate?
And so the decision to
invest in teenagers,
which almost all of us do
in one way or another--
that's a priority.
To me, that defines
civic engagement--
figuring out what groups
of students we work with.
Thinking about where
the relationship of--
you had originally asked about
the humanities and museums
and what's going on there.
And of course, then, you
begin to think, OK, well,
here in this august beautiful
hall, we're part of the, what,
400 selective liberal arts
institutions in the country,
of which there are almost 4,000.
So that means the majority
are not, quote unquote,
"highly" selective,"
which means they
don't accept more than 50%.
So not even that selective.
No offense.
And so I think about,
civic engagement really
is a set of choices
about who are
our partners institutionally.
Who are the people we
serve, and to what degree?
Because again, we're all trying
to do pretty much everything.
But I think that there are real
choices and real consequences
to all of the choices
we make, whether it's
to work together on a
letter about NEA and NEH
funding-- self-serving on
the one hand, of course,
but speaking very much
to a national policy
and an investment in our future.
Or many of us are part
of an amicus brief
filed for the Supreme Court
challenging the travel ban.
At many different
levels, I'd say,
we are all quite proactive.
And that is one way of thinking
about civic engagement.
- Your point about the
budget is really well taken.
I mean, even when we have
to sit down and decide how
to use our marketing dollars--
it's a huge engagement question.
- Right.
And to whom?
It sort of goes back
to the city issue,
which is, where's all
of the new building?
Where's the new Boston,
the Boston that's on fire?
Well, it's not in
Dorchester, by and large.
I can tell you that.
I was this morning in
Dudley at a meeting,
and it's mostly
not there either.
East Boston is going to
be my neck of the woods
with the strip there.
It's the strip of the
waterfront, which is going
to be quite expensive condos.
Meanwhile, it's a neighborhood
of 58% immigrants, mostly
Central American.
So there's these
three communities
in tension-- the long-term
Italian working class
families, all these
immigrants, and now
all the new people
buying condos.
So we all make
complicated choices,
but we do make those choices.
- Well, because you brought
up the humanities, Jill--
- I did that for you.
- It's true.
Originally, we
thought very much--
universities are focused on
the humanities and particularly
the need with every generation
to champion the humanities.
And this may fall more into the
what, as opposed to the why,
in Matthew's formulation.
But let me ask a slightly
different question that's
more specific to museums and
museum collections, which
has to do with the study
of the art of the past.
Two of you are overseeing
museums that are specifically
contemporary art museums--
although how we define
"contemporary art"
is, of course, ever-evolving.
And Matthew, you come from a
contemporary art background,
although you oversee
an encyclopedic museum.
There does seem to be,
at least from where
I sit in an academic art
history department, more
and more of a presentist
turn among students.
You see the ascendancy of
contemporary art in the art
world as well.
Within this situation,
what is the value
of the study of the
art of the past?
How does it relate
to the presentation
of contemporary art.
Are we too presentist in our
presentation of art right now?
- They're the ones
with the collections.
[LAUGHTER]
- Well, if I can jump in, being
a collection largely of the art
of the past-- although we have
a very active contemporary
program and an
artist-in-residence program
that's 25 years old.
Actually, Jill was
involved in its inception
when she was at
the Gardner Museum,
and now we have a wonderful
curator of contemporary art
who oversees the program.
I'm going to go back to your
very first question, in terms
of an experience from our life
that moved us or inspired us
toward museums.
And mine was with a piece of
art of what was then the past.
It was a 20th-century piece.
But now, 20th century blue chip
art is the art of the past.
I mean, it might as well
be a Renaissance painting
in many people's minds.
And I was in front of
a Franz Kline painting
and talking to a friend of
mine about the painting,
and talking about just
trying to look at the imagery
and seeing it as barbed
wire, and talking
about the brutality of war
and the invocation of violence
and this black-and-white
dichotomy.
And I passed out.
So I had a Stendhal moment,
or I was extremely moved
by the painting or something.
But I literally woke
up in a guard's office
with someone waving
smelling salts over you.
Somehow, I'd gotten from
the gallery down the stairs.
This was at the
RISD Museum of Art,
where they're used to having
students pass out, I assume--
for all kinds of reasons
other than the art.
But anyway, it
does bring me back
to this idea of both
the potency of art,
that once it's created--
I think sometimes,
because all of us,
I think, are very supportive,
very jazzed, very energized,
and deeply believe
in the creative act
and the artistic process, that
sometimes we don't equally
broadcast our conviction in
art once it has been created.
And that's what the
art of the past is.
It's art that's been created.
It's of its own time.
And that that
retains its potency,
although we unlock it
in different ways--
that's the challenge.
How do we unlock the
power of that art,
because it still
has that potential?
And that was one
lesson, one take-away.
And the other was, how much
conversation-- and this goes
back a little to different
modes of engagement,
and is it social, is it other?
Any time there's a
conversation, obviously
it has a social
component, but it also
is how we attend to art,
how we engage with art,
and how conversation can
be a facilitator that
makes the art of the
past relevant, because it
lives in the present through
our engagement with it.
And that's part of our job,
is to make art live now,
regardless of when
it was created.
I mean, that would be--
obviously, coming
from the Gardner,
I have a vested
interest in making
the art of the past live.
But I would imagine that we
all want the art of the past
to live in the present, because
we have a stake in that,
and as does the public, I think.
- So I'm in contemporary
art because I wanted
to support living artists.
I think that's the
contribution that I can make.
And depending on
which scholar you ask,
contemporary art's been
around for quite a bit.
We're 17,000 to 35,000
years, depending
on which scholar you ask,
but those cave drawings--
it goes back that far.
But I find visual arts to
be particularly interesting
because it's a very different
type of art, in that you
have to be really original.
So I'm going to be
broadly generalist here,
but in music, if you play
someone else's music really
well, you're a good artist.
If you're a singer, if you-- you
know, a la school of whoever,
you're very good.
Whereas visual arts,
if you do something
that's been done before,
people pick up on it,
and it's not for the
pedestal of our history.
You won't make it up there if
you're recreating something.
So we are all here to support
living contemporary artists.
However, all the artists
have to know art history.
If you come to us
with an object saying,
I discovered this
new way of painting--
I put cameras on the floor
and I dripped paint on it.
It's been done before.
So I think for all of us,
it's moving the art forward.
It's taking it to a place
that's nowhere it's been before.
But for the
practitioners, they have
to have to know the
craft and the history
before they can move
on to the next step.
- So behind the
strategic plan at the MFA
are a few sets of beliefs.
And one of them is, open
is better than closed.
And what I think about leading
an extraordinary staff who
take care of one of the great
collections of the world,
historical art, is that
one of my challenges
is to see historical art
as open and not closed.
And when we can achieve
that-- which is to say,
other voices can come in, when
interpretation can be complex
and not linear, when maybe we
believe in many disciplines
as well as our history--
we may open it up in a way that
creates life in those objects.
I mean one of my very first
experiences at the MFA
before I even knew really
anybody was to walk
through the Egyptian galleries.
And I just kept looking.
And I don't know a lot
about Egyptian art.
I didn't know anything then.
I know a little bit more now.
But what I know is, there are
a lot of broken noses in there.
You walk down,
and then I started
looking at the text panels, and
there wasn't one single text
panel that addressed
what you were
seeing when you walked through.
And so my legacy the MFA?
Very simple.
A room of broken noses.
It'll happen by
the time I leave.
And then text panels that
explain why the nose is broken.
And that's open, to me.
That's an open way of creating
a way of understanding
an object through the voices of
many, because to really answer
that question is complex.
It talks to religion, it talks
to a whole range of things.
And that notion of
openness is what
I think we have to achieve
in our historical collection.
- I think another thing
that can be really powerful
is artists speaking about
earlier art, particularly
the art that inspired
them themselves.
And I think that can be
wonderful for students.
It's often very
mesmerizing and compelling
for the general public
to think about the fact
that an artist, even
a very well-known one,
started somewhere.
And what were they looking
at as they began to make art?
And what has their
inquiry looked
like, and where has the art of
the past intersected with what
they're trying to do?
They can be great conversations.
- Well, I mean, it's no surprise
that we've heard so many,
I think, inspiring
formulations about the value
of the art of the past
from our participants.
And I wanted to ask--
one of the jobs of a museum
director is to be inspiring.
But as you pointed out, museums
are such complex institutions
now.
You have to manage so
many different roles.
And one of the
questions I like to ask
is how you have seen the
position of the museum director
change over the years.
What is the museum director now?
And tell us where it's leading.
What does the museum director
going to be like in the future,
in the year 2030 or beyond?
- Who knows?
- Well, the question that
none of us can answer
is what the role of
the museum director
will be in its formation
as the custodian of objects
that are increasingly valued,
increasingly rare, more
contested.
And we can't answer
that question.
There are some
trustees of the MFA
here, so I really
shouldn't say this,
but I don't actually
think being a museum
director is so complicated.
Really.
I think that you're an
advocate for the meaning of art
in your community, and you
are looking at different ways
to activate the people
with whom you work in order
to have the biggest,
loudest, most effective
platform you can create.
And if you have the
passion around what art
can do in your community,
a lot follows from that.
And we all have
extraordinary teams around us
of people who are expert in
areas that we're not expert,
and our job is to make
sure we understand
how to connect to them
so that we don't assume
that we know the answers
that other people know
better than we do.
But if the passion
is in the middle,
we can take a lot to the edges.
- I think it's
getting kind of comp--
I mean, I do think
it is complicated.
So I'll have to get a private
tutorial or something,
figure it out better.
But aren't you all struck?
I mean, we're here in a room.
Almost everyone here, from
where I sit, looks white.
- Not where I'm sitting.
- Not where you're sitting.
Are you looking out?
At the ICA, we've
just come through--
I don't even know that
we're through it--
a fairly complicated situation
regarding an exhibition we
have on view right now with
the painter Dana Schutz.
And Dana Schutz,
some of you may know,
made a painting called
Open Casket, which
depicts in a somewhat
abstracted way
the open coffin of Emmett
Till, and it was included
in the Whitney biennial.
Now, that painting
never was intended
to be part of the
ICA exhibition,
and it is not part of
the ICA exhibition,
but the controversy
of the painting
has come to the exhibition
and to the institution.
And I do think it is, as we
go forward in a city that is--
in a world that is changing
so much, that is divided,
that has real inequities
and issues, that our job--
I don't know what
it will be in 2030,
but I do think that we are
all being asked to change,
whether or not the
controversy is on our doorstep
today or last year or whatever.
We need to change our staffs,
need to change our audiences,
changing--
history needs to be
augmented and retold.
Storytelling is changing.
Digital life is changing.
And juggling all that--
now, I think I find
that complicated myself.
Challenging.
I love it.
But I don't know the answers.
And I know I have changed
myself through the Dana Schutz
exhibition and
grappling with it.
So I feel my own movement, both
personally and institutionally.
- So give us a sense
about how you've changed,
or what that movement is.
- Well, I would say--
I'm not so prepared here,
but what I would say
is that I think that what the
question has shifted to me,
is not one just of
cultural appropriation
or sensitivity to
audience, but actually
a question of authority.
And how is the issue of
cultural authority changing,
and how does it need to change,
and without stepping down
myself and getting
rid of half my staff,
how am I going to make
some of those changes
quickly enough to change
who has voices of authority
in making decisions
and understanding
the implications of decisions
we make, just for example?
So I don't know the future.
I definitely don't.
But I do find it
to be an extremely
challenging, important time
to lead a civic institution.
It's a great privilege.
But I find it a great
responsibility, and not easy.
- I think directors' role and
responsibilities will change
as the institutions change.
And right now, all of us in
addition to the visual art
world, are in flux.
So every institution, whether
it's a symphony or the opera
library--
we're all in a crisis.
We're all in crisis
mode, and we're all
looking to see how we can
reach the larger audience,
reach the next generations
of participants and users.
And so I'm sure all
the institutions will
adapt or change or disappear.
But whoever takes on
that role in 2030--
and I won't be there
for that, probably--
I'm sure the board--
and I know Matthew
says we're leaders.
We're leaders, but we're also
saying, at the same time,
middle management.
We're sort of stuck in between
our board and the people
that we serve, and we're
trying to fit where--
the best directors are
good problem solvers.
And I'm sure the board,
whoever does the hiring,
will hire the best
problem-solvers, who
are sensitive and
capable and who
can see the widest vision to
serve the best that they can
with the institution that
has given the task to.
- One of the interesting
things we heard--
some of us were there, I
think, at the last meeting
of the Association of
Art Museum Directors--
was part of a session
on philanthropy
that was held at the Gates
Foundation in Seattle.
And what we were being
told by several heads
of major philanthropic
organizations
is that the big funders,
the Gates Foundation,
funders of that category--
they want to tackle the
world's problems right now.
And unless museums can
become places for solutions,
we're going to be
out of the loop.
So if we had to guess, who
knows what 2030 will look
like, but I'm going to guess
that directors are going
to need more capacity in
terms of understanding things
that are outside of their
traditional areas of expertise,
and that they're
going to really have
to have a much
bigger understanding
of global problems.
And we're talking about poverty,
disease, climate change,
migration.
How museums will engage with
these issues will probably
vary from institution
to institution,
but I think among
other pressures,
philanthropists are going
to insist that we engage
with the problems of our world.
The other thing that the
Gates fellow said, and--
there was another flap, because
there was not just that,
but he certainly said
that powerfully--
but that their support
was going to go
to those cultural institutions
that cross disciplines and that
actually found a way to partner
outside of the discipline
of the cultural institution.
And I don't know if
that's temporary or not.
But picking up on what
Jill said-- and I continue
to think it's not that
complicated, although I do
think that it takes a lot
of attention and openness.
But I do think
what you're saying,
which is extraordinary,
powerful, and is
something that I think about a
lot, is, who speaks for whom?
And that's part of what you're
saying about the Dana Schutz
situation.
I think that is the question
of authority of institutions.
But what I mean by saying that
it's not that complicated which
I guess maybe it
is-- but what I mean
is, the way to get
to the solution,
if you accept that
it's a process, that it
is an engagement and
conversation with others,
you can get there.
It's not intractable.
It's not impossible.
It's the fact that
we can't predict
where we're going to be in
25 years it doesn't mean
that the process
of getting there
doesn't have immediate
and consequential rewards.
That's what I'm saying.
- This is such a
rich discussion.
I think this might
be a nice moment
to open it up to
the audience and ask
for anybody who would to
ask could pose a question
to approach the microphone
in the center aisle.
And when you do
pose your question,
if you could state your
name and any affiliation,
that would be great.
- Hi.
I'm Vanessa, and I'm a
student at the Graduate
School of Education right
now in arts and education.
And I wanted to
refer back to what
Paul was saying about
talking about educating art
practitioners
about the art canon
in order to go into
civic engagement.
And I'm thinking about
Boston as a city,
and as we were talking about
bringing the arts into Boston.
And I'm from LA, and
it's a cultural hub,
and I see programs
like the Getty's PSTLA,
and many museums' programs
where they engage directly
with artists, working artists.
And that usually comes in
the university setting.
So what I want to ask is,
how does the institution
of the museum engage with the
institution of the academy
through the university
and its artists,
and then how does that
funnel into the engagement
of these institutions
with the city?
Does that make sense?
- Is that directed to me or--?
- Go for it.
- OK.
I think it's a great title,
"The Museum, the City,
and the University," but I
think that's one thing that's
glaringly missing for
me, which is The Artist.
I think "the artist" should
have been included in the title,
because without
artists, there's no art.
There is an ecosystem
to the art world,
and the two institutions
that you mentioned,
the teaching institutions
and the museums.
But in addition to that,
there's also alternative spaces.
There's artists.
There's collectors.
And all those things help--
and galleries.
And we're losing
more-- we lost Camilo,
who ran a very excellent
gallery in Boston Samson.
And so I think
when I said Boston
has this within a
renaissance of visual arts,
We are missing a
couple of things here.
And one thing that we need
to shore up or support
or to be aware of, and perhaps
point towards helping it grow,
is the artist community, and
an alternative space community
and gallery community.
That's three out of
five that I mentioned,
which is not a good percentage.
However, since the museums and
the public scholarly teaching
institutions are so strong,
it sort of can make up for it.
But we do need, I
think, those three areas
to somehow get there.
Boston being rich
with universities--
one thing that I'm
noticing, because we
are so close to other
metropolitan cities
is that a lot of
artists are basically
commuters out of
the nine months,
and then they go back to
whatever city they're from.
And some live in LA, which
I think is ridiculous.
So somehow, collectively,
we can think
about supporting those
three additional groups
or growing them,
I think we would
have a multiplicative
effect on the city.
- The triangle between the
museum, the university,
and the artist that was
conjured up in the question,
misses one thing for me, which
is the notion of the audience.
And I had an unfortunate
dinner party--
well, the dinner party
wasn't unfortunate,
but the conversation
for me was unfortunate,
because I made the point,
which I feel strongly
that the most important thing
a museum creates is audience.
And there were some--
I might say it with emphasis--
some Harvard academics
at the dinner, and they
were making the point
that the most important thing
museums great is knowledge.
So a good robust conversation.
It wasn't actually
unfortunate, except to say
that I think that when you
think of the relationship
of the museum, the
university, and the artist,
I think you have
to ask yourself,
in the service of what?
And I think that a robust
conversation around this
would be, what is the
audience you produce,
the enlightened citizen,
the engaged citizen?
And that's where I think that
the link between universities
and art museums can be stronger.
- My name's Laura Roberts.
I'm an independent
museum professional,
and I teach here in the
museum studies program.
I've been teaching
museum graduate
students for about 30 years.
To say there's nothing quite
like that to keep you honest,
because I'm otherwise an
age peer of most of you.
And one of the things that
those students are telling me
is that--
it's a conversation that
has erupted most recently
in the production of a T-shirt.
I have one on order that
says museums are not neutral.
What they should say on the back
is that they never have been.
And I'm wondering what
your response is to that.
If your staff came in
wearing a Museums Are
Not Neutral T-shirt,
what would you say,
and would you own a Museums
Are Not Neutral T-shirt?
- I'll answer that.
I think at a certain age,
T-shirts don't look that well.
[LAUGHTER]
I wouldn't wear one.
I don't know that--
I'm not sure that is the goal,
that museums should be neutral.
I agree that they are not
and that they have not been.
And they are not places where
everyone is comfortable.
I'm not sure comfort is
the goal of art or museums.
I think that what
is necessary is
being able to own, talk about,
be honest about one's past,
whether that's personal bias
or the history of museums
of places--
most museums-- of white
power and privilege.
So most definitely not neutral.
But I guess I would push back
at neutral as the highest goal.
I don't know.
I'd have to go to the why,
Matthew, but I'm not sure.
But if my staff wore
one, I'd be fine.
- A question would be,
what would neutral look
like in terms of a museum?
- Or period.
What does l--
- Or what does neutral--
- Like anywhere--
- look like?
- Is a sidewalk neutral?
- And I think we can all
readily investigate and discuss
how we are not
neutral spaces, both
from the history of how
collections were formed
and how the canon of art
history was developed--
frankly, to the color of the
walls and the way that art is
contextualized, all
of which influences
not just the art you see but
the way you perceive that art.
And all the
different-- before you
even get into the
museum, what you're
seeing, how you're greeted, what
the transactional relationship
is at that entry desk.
Those are all things
that influence and shape
our experience or art.
And so in so many ways,
we are not neutral spaces.
And we think we need
to acknowledge that.
But one also needs to ask the
question, what is neutral?
And what is that experience?
Because I don't know that
I've ever experienced
something at all neutral.
- I don't know where this
particular T-shirt came from,
but I know that the Museum
of Contemporary Art,
their director has proposed that
they think about it this way--
that we are not partisan,
but we are not neutral.
So in other words, "neutrality"
taking on a slightly different
connotation than "partisan."
And I think we're not neutral.
I mean, we all have
hopes of the kinds
of conversations that are going
to happen in our institutions.
We don't want to direct what
the conclusions and the answers
are, but I think we're
very interested in being
a platform for
those conversations
and using our collections
in quite pointed ways.
But I think maybe
it helps in terms
of in the kind of dichotomy
that was set up by the MCA.
Think about it that way.
- You mean in Chicago?
MCA in Chicago, Martha?
- MCA in Chicago, yeah.
- I think the idea of staff
coming into the MFA wearing
that T-shirt would be
fabulous, because it would be
the beginning of
the conversation.
If not neutral, then
what is our position,
and how do we discuss
that position?
And how do we arrive at either
an institutional position
or a series of project positions
that amount to something?
That would be a
great conversation
to be more self-aware about.
- Hi.
I am Renana Kehoe.
I work at the
Harvard Art Museums.
My question was, who
are your museums for?
And if the answer is something
like everyone or a big group,
how do you appeal to
or attract or engage
such a wide-ranging
audience or group?
- Next question?
[LAUGHTER]
I think that in some
sense at the MFA,
we think we are for everybody.
But if you look at
our strategic plan
and thought about where we
saw our areas of growth,
we're really quite specific.
And that comes back to the
question of the utility
we feel we can have
in our communities.
So to be very
precise, we believe
that we are for those people
who self-select as our members.
But beyond that, if
we think about growth,
we think of students.
We think of
multigenerational families.
And we think of
creative industries,
24- to 35-year-olds.
Because we think if we
can create conversations
for those communities in Boston
and create a sense of belonging
at the MFA--
that in other words, we
can give back to them
a purpose and a
kind of conversation
in their communities--
we can be of greater use in
the civic sense in Boston.
- I think maybe it's useful to
distinguish between who are we
for, and where are our
greatest opportunities in terms
of connection and in terms
of community relevance?
And those may be two
different things,
in the sense that
I think we want
to be for everyone in the sense
that we want we want to welcome
everyone who wants to come.
Of course we don't force
people to come to the museum--
except in school groups,
where we actually
to force people to
come to the museum.
And we could have a whole
conversation about that.
But we all, I think,
based on our institutions,
on our collections
for the Gardner,
definitely in terms of
our geographic location,
look at what our
opportunities are.
For instance, in
terms of the Gardner,
we're very focused on our
hyper-local communities
of Roxbury and Mission Hill,
who may not traditionally
have felt that the Gardner
was a place for them,
and for good reason, and
which are communities
of tremendous creativity that we
would like to collaborate with.
And so we've begun
to co-create programs
with artists and artistic
leaders in Roxbury and Mission
Hill that can be
both for tradition,
the people who
come to the Gardner
anyway, but also to
give voice to members
of our hyper-local communities
and to have them feel that they
do have a voice in the museum.
So I think all of us
try to figure out,
where are our opportunities
for each of our institutions?
And the answer may be
different for each of us.
- Because we are
not for everyone.
But if you are
curious about where
art is going in terms of future,
then we are the place for you.
And I will readily admit
that not everything we show
will end up at the
MFA in the collection.
A lot of our stuff
that we show may just
disappear into the
ether of art history.
But I feel like our job is
to present to what people
are talking about right now.
The people that I surround
myself, the people that we
have conversation with--
it's a modest proposal,
presenting something
to you and to say, what
do you think about this?
Is this something insignificant?
Or is it something that we
should absolutely throw away
and not think about ever again?
So if you want to see
something that there's
a small group of people
that's talking about,
then we're the place for you.
But if you want
generality, we're
really not the place for you.
- I don't think I
have that much to add.
The only group that
hasn't been mentioned
that is very important
to the ICA is teenagers.
We have about 7,000
teenagers a year
in the ICA in our teen programs,
and putting them together
with our artists is one of
the important constituents
that we serve.
And artists.
- Hi.
My name is Jen.
I work in the Education
Department at the MFA.
Sorry, Matthew.
- I'm glad you do.
- You'll see what
my question is.
And I just first wanted
to thank you all,
because I think this
conversation has been
super-interesting
and very energizing
for me as a museum educator.
My question is about the
very controversial topic
of unpaid internships.
And I ask because I think
it really encapsulates
museum, city, and university,
because it involves university
students.
Unpaid internships--
I think, Jill, you
might have kind of
hinted at this the most
when you were talking
about the lack of diversity
in museum staffs.
I think that's something all
museums are struggling with,
and we're really
feeling the effects
when it comes to
interpretation and exhibitions
and programming.
And unpaid internships are
often the most direct filter
into staff positions at museums.
I know that I was an MFA
intern, and now I work there.
And now, as someone that has
interns and supervises them
over the summer,
I've really been
struck by this huge lack
of diversity in applicants,
and our intern pool, both
racially but socioeconomically
as well.
I'm wondering,
because you guys are
in such influential
positions, if you
have thoughts about that.
I know it's a very
complex topic.
- I do.
I have really strong
thoughts on that.
- I thought Jill might.
- Go ahead.
- Thank you.
I have the mixed
pleasure of chairing
the professional Issues
committee at AAMD,
which is the Association of Art
Museum Directors, to which we
all participate, more or less.
And at our last meeting in--
wherever we were, Seattle--
I put on the agenda the
issue of paid internships
to try to see whether that is
something that we as a field
could actually adopt as
a policy in the same way
we have other
field-wide policies
that govern our behavior and
our practice, our accreditation,
et cetera.
And actually, this past
summer, for the first time,
the ICA only had paid
interns, and we're trying
to embody that going further.
There was a mixed
response, I would say--
not against it in
principle, but in practice,
for a variety of reasons.
And so I think it
won't be a slam dunk,
but there are national
foundations who
are trying to push this agenda.
I think we as a group of peers
and as a field are grappling
with it, though it may take us a
little time to have one policy.
And I think as we all begin to
work in our own institutions,
we see it.
We understand it and see it.
Because, welcome to our field.
We need more people like
you, and we need more people
not like you.
- Thank you.
- So I believe in paying
interns and fellows.
I think it's really important.
But I'll go even further.
In one of my older institutions,
we created a teen program.
It was a weekend
program, where we
thought we created
this fantastic program
for underprivileged youth.
And it was free.
Absolutely free.
And when we started getting
people to participate,
it all turned out that the
only people who signed up
were from the suburbs, who
went to private school.
And we just couldn't figure out
why people weren't signing up,
because obviously, this is
an incredible program free
of charge.
And then we had a meeting
with a bunch of people,
and they said, well, those
people you're trying to reach--
they work on the weekends.
They need to make
money to support
and help support their family.
And additional to that, they
don't have the transportation
money to come to your museum.
So we ended up finding a sponsor
to pay for the bus passes.
And we paid them--
we started with minimum
wage, but that's what we did.
But that's when I realized there
was a disconnect between what
we thought was great and
what was the reality of life.
And even though we mean
well, we really sometimes
have it all wrong.
- We pay our teams.
- Yeah.
Of course you do.
- Thank you.
I really appreciate the honesty.
- Hi, there.
I'm Elizabeth Solomon.
I'm an alum of Radcliffe.
I currently work at the
School of Public Health,
and I'm a degree candidate in
the museum studies program.
As one of the few brown
people in the audience,
I was gratified to
hear a lot of talk
about civic engagement,
inclusion, issues of power
and voice and authority.
But also, as a museum consumer
who's spent significant time
in every single one of the
museums except the MIT Museum--
I'm sorry, I will visit.
- Nobody visits us.
[LAUGHTER]
- But I'm really interested,
and having spent a lot of time
and found that a lot of times my
perspectives are not recognized
and/or presented within museums,
and sometimes, in some cases,
are really kind of--
in some cases actually in
ways that are disrespectful.
And I'm wondering what
your plans and goals are
for operationalizing
some of these things
that you've been talking about.
Because I think they're
very lofty goals,
but how are you
going to move forward
in terms of realizing them?
- So we began a
program at the MFA
to give free memberships
to naturalized Americans
in the state of Massachusetts.
And we've set as a goal
that we will judge ourselves
in five to seven years
on how many of those
new members become either
gallery guides or staff
members.
And the question for
us will be, how do we
create that virtuous connection,
so that we can invite people
in, welcome them as belonging,
and engage them in creating
meaning in the institution?
And I think that
until you accept
that you have to invite people
in to help create meaning,
which is my point about
voice, in the end,
you won't get that
true connection.
It's a big challenge,
and it's an exciting one.
- I think you ask a
very good question.
I know one of the
things we've done
is work with some outside
help, bring in outside help
to train our staff.
We've actually invited
our colleagues,
staff from our
sister institutions
for training on how to
engage with visitors
around complex works
of art where there
might be difference of opinion
or difficult subject matter,
doing--
I'm not sure.
I understood your
question to be,
how are we
operationalizing this, yes?
And so I think it's lots
of training and lots
of repetition,
actually, especially
because typically, a lot of our
front-of-house staff is young,
and there's a fairly
high turnover rate.
So it is constant, but it
is a combination, I'd say,
of top-down and bottom-up.
It's both/and.
- I would also say--
and I'm very fortunate that
one of our curatorial staff
is here--
in terms of operationalize,
how do you integrate this
into the conceptualisation
from the beginning of programs,
exhibitions, et cetera?
And so one of our upcoming
shows opening in October
is on Henry James and
American painting.
Not a subject you would
necessarily think.
It's going to be a very
momentous exhibition,
as you can tell.
The heavens will move.
Anyway, not an exhibition that
you would on face value think
might lend itself to a lot
of exploration of connections
with things happening
now or everyday life,
the other kinds of things.
But in fact, networks, artistic
networks, creative networks,
are intrinsic to the
whole idea of Henry James
and his connections
with Isabella Stewart
Gardner and John Singer
Sargent, et cetera, et cetera.
And so the curator
actually decided
to work with someone
who is in one
of the groups of
artistic advisers
from our local community to
think about how we would embed
that idea of current
network, artistic networks
and creative networks within
our communities today.
How do we embed that in
the exhibition itself,
not only in the programs
for the exhibition
but in the interpretive strategy
for the exhibition, et cetera?
And I'm so moved and proud
of this collaboration,
because it was actually
operationalizing
and a way of giving--
opening up the
types of voices that
can enter the museum in a
major, major project that
requires very heavy investment.
Exhibitions are one
of our most cost-
and labor-intensive
endeavors, as I
think anyone in our
institutions would confirm.
And so that's one example of
how we can begin to do that.
But I think one is
also talking about,
how do you institutionalize
experimentation?
Because none of us have
the right answer to this.
It's going to take a
lot of experimentation,
a lot of trying things.
And I would say that
that's one of the biggest
challenges to museums, is
how do you keep something--
how do you remain an
adaptive institution
once you start operationalizing
and institutionalizing things?
- And part of that may
be institutionalizing
institutional critique.
So museums have been addicted
to big data and metrics
and visitor research,
but we've maybe not
invited the same
kind of scrutiny
in terms of institutional
critique of what we're
acquiring, of what we're
showing, how we're showing it.
I had a very interesting
experience this year
walking through the galleries
with a faculty member
and her class who were taking
a very specific journey
through the museum because of
the subject of their class.
And they were able
to find some real--
some not-so-good things
that were happening,
because our curators were all
installing their galleries
separately and weren't
thinking about what
the whole journey might look
like through the galleries.
So now, with some help
from this faculty member
and her students,
we're actually trained
to think in a more holistic way.
So I think outside partners can
sometimes critique us in a way
that we would never
do for ourselves.
- One group that hasn't been
mentioned, except in passing,
that makes so much
of this possible,
supporting all of our
welcome and openness,
is that we are all incredibly
lucky to have these amazing
boards of trustees and
advisers who in Boston--
and this is a different
kind of architecture.
And Boston is not a city
with a lot of foundations.
It doesn't have a lot
of corporate support.
It has an unbelievably engaged
group of philanthropists.
And so it is a partnership
that coexists along
with the partnership we
have with our scholars
and our artists and our teachers
and our audiences and our teams
and families.
But it is part of the ecosystem
that Paul was talking about,
and a really critical piece.
- Thank you for what was
really a terrific, honest,
and searching conversation.
So please join me.
Thank you.
[APPLAUSE]
[MUSIC PLAYING]